welcome to this video playing link must
link miss from the US tango okay I
remember he's studying in the US or
working maybe studying considering his
age as a younger player the one of the
best players in Belgium so we have a
Slav with queen bees for just my normal
line 93-94 probably
this Knight e5 an idea in this position
they're probably not and now come on
spending too much time for simple moves
yeah yeah like does not have any
problems 97 is this a move now or is
this crazy
97 probably takes takes on a fade
not really not really so let's see
yeah it's a really not so exciting
position
trading Queens or not it's not so clear
what this was the queen is well-placed
or not but neither four is really a move
that that is doing totally nothing so
maybe I can can at least try to get this
this weird a one Bishop traded I ever
play c5 at the end and I am NOT not the
end of the world niya is drawn with her
oh well yeah that one now I wanted to go
rook t2 takes takes but he has c5 at the
end it's not a good this is not really
good played this far too far to in a far
too simple fashion giving him the more
more comfortable game him okay
trying to activate the night via e3 but
he's got the only open file that's quite
important of course I mean I'm not
overly worried but I should be I just
belong des here okay what's a bad game
that was really like losing like a
little child here trading off in the
wrong spots then giving up blundering
this pawn basically
check yeah if I advance I'm giving up
this poem not great
yeah I mean I better take it as long as
I'm able to I can maybe check try this
here for some some counterplay not
really yeah as a bonus is far too quick
well at least I'm threatening something
check something like g6
it still should be a fairly easy win
takes here I have to do that anyway time
warning g7 he's checking first that's
the problem I don't have checks there
which is seven look h1g eight Queen and
I don't have a check with my new queen
that's really unfortunate
well that wins as well of course I can't
give up him this was just this was just
player just played this like a complete
idiot
I mean trading down to a worse end game
I really didn't have any big big idea
anyway but at least I mean this is like
totally equal I just need to be need to
be alert and and yeah there's still
nothing going on I just blundered this
pawn now if I I don't know whatever I
have three or something then there's
nothing happening I don't know maybe
maybe this this is this is easier yeah
does he have a pool maybe he has a pool
here oops not with this with Ruby three
yeah ninety-four it's not sheriff it's
it's not really great I mean it wasn't
like it wasn't playing for draw one or
something it's not like I'm afraid here
or anything but I didn't I didn't really
I didn't have anything so I went for
this and this this is somewhat
uncomfortable really a compounds to do
with that move but I thought that this
now
it's also equal if you are not totally
brain-dead like I am maybe also before
before you that ok yes got a pawn yeah
it was it was really the the the real
deal here or the real problem was that
here played this very unassuming nice
ninety three and this is this is giving
him a very easy game really after that
it's over with any pretensions for an
advantage and not good well okay thanks
for watching